[MUSIC PLAYING]
EUGENE LIDERMAN: Before
I dive into the talk,
I kind of want explain
the team and the strategy
and what we focus on.
So first and foremost,
we're dedicated to improving
the security and privacy for
Android's 2 billion-plus users,
all right?
And we have three pillars
that we kind of focus on.
So first and foremost, it's
layered security, right?
I mean, you hear
it all the time,
defense in depth, the onion,
layered security model.
So everything we do,
we try to think of it
as we want to use as much of the
hardware-based features we can.
We always try to lock
things down in the OS
with regards to apps,
sandboxing, and APIs,
and then we always try to
we add additional controls
for app-related security, right?
And then we try
really hard-- it's
part of our ethos to be as
transparent and as open as
possible with our ecosystem,
with our partners,
with our customers,
with the user base.
And so we do that in a
couple of different ways.
First, we-- obviously
Android is open source.
We publish-- I mean, you
see every commit we make.
So people can see
oftentimes people
write about the new
changes because you
can see the commits that are
added to Android Open Source.
Second, we publish
a lot of blogs.
I think for security
specifically,
we published like
30 blogs last year.
And it was-- it's
really twofold.
It's one, to educate developers
about all these new security
features they can
take advantage of,
and the second part is it's
to educate the research
community about the
strides that we're making.
So we're continuously
publishing blogs
about new features, new
functionality, new techniques
that we're taking advantage of.
We also publish a quarterly
transparency report,
which is kind of like a state
of the ecosystem in terms
of health around malware
and potentially harmful--
what we refer to as potentially
harmful applications.
And then we also publish a
monthly security bulletin.
So you can see what we're fixing
every month with these security
bulletins.
And we actually also publish--
not to get too long on this,
but an annual year in review
as well, which is like
a recap of everything
I just covered already.
So we try to provide
a lot of information.
We want to educate
people on what's
going on with regard to
Android and the ecosystem.
And the last piece is we
leverage the rest of Google.
So Google's got tremendous
security and privacy expertise.
Security reviews are done
in-house collectively.
Incident management is done
internally collectively.
We partner with the
Safe Browsing team,
which we'll cover a bit later.
We work really closely
with the Identity team--
so around advanced protection,
leveraging like hardware keys
on mobile devices.
We leverage insights
on machine learning
and artificial intelligence
into our products,
so we get a lot of the
knowledge from the rest
of the other organizations
within Google.
And so in terms of our actual
team, the Security and Privacy
team, it's broken down into
three distinct subgroups.
The first is the Google
Play Protect team.
So this is our built-in
anti-malware protection
solution.
It's really to protect
against third party
harmful, malicious
applications and content.
It also provides
a user experience
on the client side where a
user can launch the application
and kind of see their
posture in terms
of the status of how many
apps have been scanned
and your kind of
security posture.
Second, we have our
platform engineering team.
This team is the
one that actually
implements a lot of
the security features
into Android Open Source.
So kind of like I
mentioned before,
continuously leveraging
the hardware-based security
features of the device,
enhancements and sandboxing,
API hardening, kernel
updates and so forth.
And then the third team is
the Android Security Assurance
team.
This team's purpose is really to
release the security bulletins.
They handle the security
development lifecycle,
they approve all
security-related features,
they do all the reviews.
And they don't just do
this for AOSP and Pixel,
they do this for the
entire ecosystem.
So they work with the system
on chip vendors, the device
manufacturers, the carriers,
the research community.
So we have a large
footprint in terms
of what we impact from
the security and privacy
perspective.
So I tried to change things
up for this presentation
and think about it in a way
like-- usually security is
something where it's
very transparent,
it's under the hood.
Good security you
don't recognize,
so I wanted to show
in a different lens
where some things are still
under the hood but some things
I want to cover that--
even on your devices you
can take a look if you're--
By the way, how many
Android users are out here?
Who actually use
Android as their device,
not that they
support internally?
That's right, that's right,
that's not a trick question--
yeah, I see you.
Just kidding.
[LAUGHS]
OK, cool.
That's good to know, thank you.
I'm not picking on
you, I'm just kidding.
OK, so what I really
want to cover,
it's broken down into
four distinct groups
and I'll explain
them really quickly.
So system-- in terms of
the operating system,
this is like stuff people can
exfiltrate off the device,
like a malicious attack--
not the end users
themselves in terms
of introducing known risk, but
something-- a malicious stack
will try to do exfiltrate
off the device.
There's apps-- there's two
kinds of categories there.
There's kind of
the app developers
that just make mistakes
and they build faulty apps
because they're not
security experts,
and there's app developers
that actually purposely come up
with malicious
applications and they're
trying to somehow steal data
or fool the user, right?
Malware-related stuff.
Third is phishing, which
I think is probably
one of the more critical
things because it's
ubiquitous across devices.
And it's not really related
to the OS or the technology
of the OS, per se,
but it's something
that just applies whatever,
via email, SMS, and so forth.
And then the fourth one I
want to cover is the end user.
And it sounds a little
redundant because like,
don't all of these impact
the end user somehow?
Well yes, but the first
three are kind of like,
these are things that--
kind of think of
it as like these
are things that attack the user,
external sources trying to get
information from the user.
And the end user themselves
is kind of like--
well shoot, end users kind
of create their own risk.
They do a lot of
self-infliction.
A lot of IT people
in the room, I'm
sure everybody here is
thinking the end user
is the weakest link.
I don't want to think that.
I think very
positively, and I think
that with proper
education and guidance,
end users can go a long way.
So diving into the
system, thinking of things
like potentially rooting the
device or somebody trying
to pull information off
an encrypted device,
recovering keys off
converting bugs into exploits,
network-related security issues
like man in the middle,
man in the browser.
So starting with-- like I
mentioned, the secure hardware,
it all starts with secure
hardware with Android.
So Android heavily relies on the
trusted execution environment
on these devices.
So anyone that's not
familiar with the TEE,
it's basically a secure OS that
runs parallel to the Android OS
on the same
application processor,
but it's segregated using
software and hardware
from the actual Android OS.
So it's like--
Android OS is the rich user
OS, TEE is a much more slimmed
down, lockdown OS.
And it's used for a lot of the
critical security features.
So just as an example, it's used
for key generation, signing,
encryption, decryption.
It's used for secure lock
screen, pin verification when
you type in your
pin, and of course,
the encryption on the
device, whether it's
a file-based encryption
and so forth.
It's also used for
version binding.
So if you generate key
material in a newer OS
and like a malicious attack
would try to downgrade that OS,
those keys would not be
available on an older OS.
And the same can be said for
rollback prevention, which
was added in Android Oreo.
And rollback
prevention is basically
where once you're at a certain
OS or security patch level,
somebody could not
downgrade that to a lower
level to be able to-- if
there was a known issue
or exploit that they
could take advantage of,
it wouldn't be able to do that.
And of course, Verified Boot
is also equally as important.
Verified Boot is basically
if you think of malware,
the first thing a piece
of malware would try to do
is modify the system
partition and ensure that it
can persist after a reboot.
And with Verified Boot, when
the device is booting up,
it cryptographically verifies
every piece of the boot process
step by step and if
something bad happens,
it alerts the user.
And in some cases, if there's
two copies of the OS, which
we'll cover a
little later, it can
revert to the known good copy.
And something that we
added in Android Pie
is tamper-resistant hardware.
So with Pie now, we basically
have the support where app
developers-- and I'll cover
some of this in-depth later on--
can basically store key
material in discrete,
tamper-resistant
hardware-- think of it
as a secure element.
It's a separate ship separate
from the application processor,
and it's got its own CPU
memory and flash storage.
And it's basically-- it
provides a higher assurance.
So it's impervious
or protects better
against physical attacks, side
channel attacks, and so forth,
OK?
So moving up outside of TEE and
the tamper-resistant hardware,
Android starts with the Android
kernel, which of course is
built off the Linux kernel.
Since Android 4.4, SELinux has
implemented mandatory access
control.
And basically
that's a very locked
down-- think of its principle
of least privileged access.
So for people-- for
SELinux, it's basically
everything is broken down
into little components that
are domains, and if
something gets exploited
in one particular domain, it's
contained within that domain,
so it doesn't mean that the
whole system gets compromised.
And then moving further up,
obviously everything is--
a sandbox.
Every application is a
sandboxed within Android
because it relies
on the Linux kernel.
And what's a little bit
different between Android
and traditional Linux is
that every process actually
has its own unique identifier.
So unlike Linux,
traditional Linux
where every process is
tied to that specific Linux
user that's logged,
in this case,
every process is tied to--
it has its own unique UID.
And in this case, that's what
makes everything sandbox,
so every process has access
to its own resources,
its own memory, its own storage.
And in order to
share information,
you have to use system features
to be able to share information
across, right?
So it's completely isolated.
We take it a step further
with the work profile, which
I'm going to cover in
much more depth later,
so I'm just going
to really quick
is that the work profile is
actually a separate Linux user.
So imagine-- and I'll
show screenshots of this--
who's here is familiar with
Android Enterprise real quick?
Anybody?
Couple of you?
Oh, that's really good.
So-- was it because
there was an earlier
session you saw about this?
Anybody-- was there another
Android Enterprise session?
Oh, good to know.
So I'll cover it a
little bit later,
but the work profile is a
really elegant user experience
where it's basically
a second Linux
user in the same
pane of glass, so
that all the data that
is in the work profile
is completely separate.
It's got its own set
of encryption keys
that can be managed by IT.
They can be evicted when
you log out, and provides
that additional control, which
I'll dive into a little bit
later.
So next up is anti-exploitation.
This is like the
toughest slide for me
to cover because
it's so technical.
But basically, there's
a big misconception
about bugs and vulnerabilities
and how they're exploitable.
Just because there's a bug,
obviously these operating
systems are hundreds of
thousands and millions
lines of code, and so
it's inevitable there's
going to be bugs.
It's inevitable that there
could be a vulnerability,
but it doesn't mean that a bug
has to be exploitable, right?
It'd be turned into
an exploit that can
compromise the system, right?
So over the years,
we've-- actually,
this is one of the key themes
that we've been adding year
over year, is additional
anti-exploitation techniques.
And so for example, everybody's
really with address space
layout randomization.
We had that in the
user space for years.
We actually added that
in the kernel in Oreo.
Randomizing memory makes
it difficult to target
exploited code and
privileged components.
We have hardened user
copy that prevents
overflow using system APIs.
PAN emulation
provides the kernel
from accessing
user space memory.
And then when-- in Pie we add
a control flow integrity which
basically instrument runtime
operations to fail gracefully
if some undefined
behavior occurs.
So again, the real thing is
that just because it's a bug
doesn't-- just because you have
a bug doesn't mean it can be
exploited, right?
And so again, we
talked about-- just
to quickly recap, the
hardware-based security
stuff above in terms
of the Android kernel
and everything there, and
then the anti-exploitation
techniques.
So one of the things
that people always ask,
because one of the ways
we try to measure success
is externally, right?
So one of the ways
we try to measure
this is through vulnerability
reward pricing, right?
That's kind of a supply
and demand situation.
And so if you look at this,
this is basically pricing
of our vulnerability
rewards versus Apple's.
These are both publicly
available on both [INAUDIBLE]..
Like their site, our site.
And what you'll see is that
they're pretty much on par
with Android
actually paying more
for certain categories
of exploits.
And so you can kind of imagine,
based on supply and demand,
if it's harder to do, it's
going to cost more money, right?
But again, this is our pricing,
so this is a little subjective.
So the next scenario then is,
what about third party pricing?
So one of the big research
competitions when it comes
to mobility is Mobile Pwn2Own.
It's in Tokyo,
Japan, every year.
And what you'll see over
the last three years,
the pricing between
Google devices and iPhones
has steadily become equal.
And so in 2018 they were
actually completely equal.
And what's interesting about
Pwn2Own, in the last two years,
the Pixel 2 was in
Pwn2Own 2017 and 2018,
it was not exploited in
either of those years.
There were some Android
devices that were exploited,
but they were not using
vulnerabilities in Android Open
Source.
They basically had specific
custom applications
that were basically exploited.
It was nothing to do
with Android Open Source.
And in comparison,
the iPhone was
pwned, as the term is,
twice in competition
and once after time had expired.
So another piece in terms of
the system security, obviously
network security.
Way back when, I remember
doing security demos.
The easy one was the--
you convince a user to
install a root certificate,
self-signed root certificate,
and you run mitmproxy
and it's like the coolest
demo-- scares everybody away.
That's not a reality
anymore, right?
And so network security has
steadily been improving release
after release.
So in Pie, we mandated
TLS by default. Also,
app developers actually
have a lot of flexibility
in terms of like even
making it more secure.
So you can do TLS leaf pinning
by simply modifying the network
security config in your
application, at which point
you can just pin
specific connections.
As of Android
Nougat/Android 7.0,
we added basically
restrictions where
all applications on the phone,
unless they explicitly opt out,
will only trust the
built-in root certificate
authorities that ship on
the device, which are then
updated by us over the year.
So-- I mean, that's really
what negates the whole
mitmproxy or installing a
self-signed root certificate.
And then from a privacy
perspective in Pie,
we actually added something we
call DNS over TLS, which is--
we were the first major
mobile OS to do this.
And this basically takes
all your DNS traffic
and encrypts it as well, right?
So somebody can't
see what request
you're making if you're on
some other Wi-Fi network,
for example, or the carrier.
And the last one is a
specific-- excuse me--
Pixel Nexus feature.
It's called Wi-Fi Assistant,
where basically it
allows you to connect
to public Wi-Fi
and then launches a Google VPN
built in for you automatically.
Of course, for people that don't
have Pixel or Nexus devices,
there's dozens of
VPN providers if you
wanted to do that, third
party ones in the Play Store.
So the next thing is we
talk about all these amazing
features we keep
adding, but users
need to install these features.
And so one of the things
we do, like I mentioned,
is we provide monthly security
bulletins to the ecosystem.
So, I mean, different OEMs
pick them up different times,
but in terms of
enterprise customers,
we have-- if nobody's familiar
with Android Enterprise,
it's recommended where those
customers are picking them up
at max at 90 days, and some
are doing it at monthly.
And so we provide
these security updates,
they're completely separate
from feature updates, right?
We do dessert releases
which are annual,
and those are all the lumpy--
big-- lots of features.
Security updates are
meant to be small
so they can go through
the system quickly,
people can vet them and they can
get installed on these devices.
One thing that we
added in Android Nougat
was called Seamless
Updates or A/B Updates.
And this is really
convenient feature
because users have
this tendency,
they don't want to run updates.
Who remembers like these
Windows updating and you
see this blue screen
and it's just updating,
updating, updating, updating.
So with Android Seamless,
it's similar to Chrome OS
with its seamless updates.
What happens is there's
two copies of the operating
system on the device.
And so when you're running
the primary copy, the A copy,
it's downloading and installing
the B copy in the background
while the user is idling.
So on a phone, it's
basically when the device
is plugged into power and just
idling on Wi-Fi, no impact
to the user.
And then like you
see there, I actually
took these screenshots, hence
it's so late in the evening.
I was cramming
for this, I guess.
And so you can see that
the user gets prompted
with a notification,
and all they have to do
is hit Restart and boom,
you're up and running.
And the cool thing is,
when it reboots the device,
it basically verifies
that new copy.
And if anything bad happens, it
simply reverts to the old copy.
No loss of user data, no impact
to the user, very elegant
experience.
So that was a Nougat and Oreo.
How many people are
familiar Project Treble?
One, two.
OK, good to know.
So Project Treble-- this
is actually really cool.
So Project Treble is an
enhancement we made in Oreo.
It's mandatory on
all Oreo and devices
that ship with Oreo and newer.
And basically it's a
further abstraction
between the firmware and the OS.
And this is actually
a feature that enables
OEMs to update much quicker.
And so we've seen a lot
of progress to this.
So you can see on
the far right there,
there's some of the OEMs.
So like by the end of last
year, all of those OEMs
had devices updated to
Pie, from Oreo to Pie.
And we actually saw, compared
to the previous year from Nougat
to Oreo, a 3x
increase of devices
that updated from Nougat
to Oreo versus Oreo to Pie.
So a lot more--
it's really so far
benefited quite a bit.
So kind of to--
I thought I put my phone on Do
Not Disturb, it's so strange.
Sorry.
So anyways, Android patching has
improved as a result of Treble
and like the other
seamless updates.
Our partner programs, just
some of the quick stats,
and this is in our
annual year in review.
Over 1 billion-plus devices
were patched in 2018.
More specifically in Q4,
almost 30% of devices more
were patched in Q4 of 2018
than the previous quarter.
And year over year,
in Q4 of 2018,
we had 84% more devices patched
than in the same quarter
of the prior year.
So patching has
improved, which is really
good for the ecosystem, right?
So then focusing on apps.
Like I mentioned earlier,
there are two types--
I look at it two types.
There's faulty apps-- developers
are making accidental mistakes.
They're not trying to be
malicious with what they're
doing, but they're basically
running through-- they're just
not experts in certain things.
And then there's the
malicious apps, right?
Malware, malicious apps trying
to exfiltrate data from users
and be annoying
with them, right?
So examples of
poorly-written apps
is like with transport security,
improper certificate path
elevation, and so forth, right?
So our way of handling
this, of course,
is you've heard people, process,
tools, this is my version--
policy, education,
and technology.
So in terms of policy,
obviously there's
the developer policy
guidelines that are online.
Developers must follow these.
There's a lot about
security and abuse
and so forth that
they need to abide by.
From an education perspective,
we spent a lot of time
like notifying
developers of when
we make policy changes,
what they need to do
to abide by these changes.
We provide tutorials
for these changes,
and I'm going to cover
a good example there.
And on the technology side,
think of it as the guardrails,
right?
So like we insure in case
they do mess something up
or something that's more
like the malicious scenario,
we have the tools in place
to protect against that, OK?
So here's a really good example.
This is actually from a blog we
launched in December of 2017.
And this was something
where we announced
that we were mandating
that developers
use Target API Level 26.
So basically in their
apps, they targeted--
with every release, when we
make security enhancements,
it's tied to a specific
dessert feature release.
And so there's an
API-level version.
So API Level 26 was Oreo.
And in this case, we said
that as of August of 2018,
any new application that's being
submitted to the Play Store
must meet that target API level,
and in November, any updates
must also meet that
target API level.
And so some examples of
where that improved ecosystem
is, we added runtime permissions
in Lollipop, API Level 23.
We added the built-in using
only the default trustStore
in API Level 24,
which is Nougat.
And like I said, in Pie
we had TLS by default,
which is API Level 28.
So we notified the developers.
We provided them
plenty of tutorials.
We actually put this right
in the Developer Play Console
where when they would
submit an application,
they would see this kind of a
heads-up-- hey, this is coming,
this is coming.
And the good news is that
this year, we had about--
we had actually had pretty
much close to 100%--
everybody, I mean,
complied, right?
They had to.
That was where the
technology came in.
If they didn't,
their new updates
weren't going to
get approved, right?
So what's really
cool about this now
is that we've set
the standard, and now
we just had a blog
come out in February
of this year doing the same
thing now with API Level 28.
So every year we're
going n minus 1,
so right now, the same time
this year, August and November,
they have to update
to API Level 28, which
now will mandate new features
that they have to apply, right?
That will apply to
their applications.
So another really neat
program, and this is the--
back to the technology
aspect of this
is the Play App Security
Improvement Program.
Has anybody heard
of this program?
When I joined, this was
like the coolest thing.
So what this does is-- this
is basically started in 2014.
And again, this is
for developers just
to make mistakes.
They might be using the wrong
version of OpenSSL that might
have a known vulnerability.
Their app might be susceptible
cross-site scripting.
They're not doing proper
certificate validation.
There's actually 31 total
classes of vulnerabilities,
and we added, I
think, eight in 2018.
And what this does is when
they submit the app to the Play
Developer Console, it's like
a free scan that they get.
And so when this
app gets scanned,
when their app is
submitted, they get scanned.
If there's an issue
that it gets found,
it pops up an alert
in the console,
it gives them a tutorial
on how to fix that issue,
it sends them an email.
And the really neat
thing about this program
is as you can see to date
since we launched the program,
we've helped over
300,000 app developers
fix over a million applications.
So it's something they
just get for free--
like a free assessment,
security assessment
of their application.
And again, it's not for
malicious applications,
it's just for developers
that are making mistakes.
And then the last thing, just
like with seamless updates,
just to cover a super
quick, is the Play
Store also does auto updates
and it does this by default.
App developers also
release security
fixes to their applications.
And just like seamless
updates for the device,
if the device is powered and
connected to Wi-Fi and idle,
these updates run
in the background.
No user intervention required.
And it's really
meant to just ensure
that they're always
running the latest
version of the application.
Obviously there's some
benefit to the user experience
because they always
add new features.
There's also a huge benefit
from the security side
because they're getting
the latest and greatest
on the security side as well.
So next up is the
malware aspect.
And so obviously you
heard in the news,
we know that there's articles
about Android and malware,
but malware is a universal risk.
It doesn't just impact Android,
it impacts every operating
system out there.
And so just a couple
of example headlines.
I mean, it even impacts
the iPhone and iOS, right?
There was actually
a recent article
that came out this week about
a new malware variant for iOS.
And there was examples
of using profiles,
using side-loading apps for
enterprise app developer
certificates, there's--
like I said, malware,
I'm not poking at
one or the other,
we all know that there's
a malware risk out there.
And so how do you
protect against malware?
Our philosophy is that malware
protection should be built in.
So if you look at Windows,
they have Defender.
If you look at Chrome and Chrome
OS, they have Safe Browsing.
And if you look at Android,
we have Google Play Protect.
How many people here are
familiar with Google Play
Protect?
Ooh, that's a good number.
Cool.
So for those that aren't--
work with me,
clicker-- there we go.
Google Play Protect is the
world's most widely-used
anti-malware solution out there.
So it basically scans
over 50 billion apps
across 2 billion devices
every single day.
It's actually a client--
it's a client application,
but it's a whole cloud
infrastructure as well.
And on the back end we actually
verify 500,000 applications
every single day, OK?
And so Play Protect
uses the combination
of machine learning, static
analysis, dynamic analysis,
heuristics, signature
checks, heat maps,
and a lot of other
techniques to identify
what we call Potentially
Harmful Applications--
PHAs for short-- which is
our terminology for malware.
And it does this for both
on Play and off Play,
because there are
users out there
in certain regions that like
to download applications,
side load applications
that are not
available on the Play Store.
And so Google Play Protect
covers those users as well.
And a really good example
from our past year in review
is that we had prevented 1.6
billion installation attempts
of potentially harmful
applications for off of Play
applications last
year alone, right?
In 2018 alone.
So again, going back to the
whole measurable security
piece, in 2018 we launched--
rather, two weeks ago, we
published our year in review,
we do this annual recap, and
one of the charts we showed
was PHA install rates over time.
And what you'll see is, the
install rate for on Play
has been very low, and
what's interesting is,
it kind of looks
like it's stagnating,
but the reality
is we're actually
adding more categories
every year--
we're adding different
variants that we didn't
think about the year before.
So it's kind of an
unfair scenario,
because if we showed only
the ones that we tracked year
after year that were the
same, it would actually
continuously go down.
But the fact that we keep
adding more and more,
it kind of provides
this view that we're
kind of going still
or consistent across.
But you can see off Play,
that number continuously
still goes down.
And so every year we have
this like-- we come up
with the nifty analogy.
They're usually really
morbid even before my time.
I don't know why they
came up with like--
two years ago it was like
the likelihood of getting hit
by a meteor, it was higher than
installing malware from PHA--
malware from the
Play Store last year
was like struck by lightning.
This year it's, you have
a higher probability
of dying in a bathtub
than installing
a potentially harmful
application on your device.
All right.
So next, phishing.
Phishing is pretty obvious.
Even though in
the last section I
talked about how malware
is a universal risk
and continued to rise, phishing
actually overtook malware.
So we, again, back to
the transparency reports,
the Safe Browsing team publishes
their own transparency report,
and what they showed is in
2016, phishing overtook malware
as the bigger attack
surface, and that has
continued through today, right?
So that trend has continued
since then-- since 2016.
And when you think of
phishing, obviously
trying to compromise
user credentials,
user info through email,
messages, SMS, any forms of--
where you can fool
a user, right?
And actually, an interesting
one that has cropped up recently
is voice-related phishing, OK?
So I'm not saying
we have the end all,
be all solutions to
protect against this,
but what I am saying is we have
a lot of built-in solutions
that users don't
know about, right?
And so Safe Browsing is a
really good example of that.
How many people are
familiar with Safe Browsing?
Everybody, yeah.
So this is cool.
So Safe Browsing
launched in 2007
to protect against
phishing and malware.
And it's built into
the Chrome browser,
so it's available across
every single operating system
out there that runs Chrome.
So that means we have 3
billion-plus devices protected,
and it examines billions of URLs
and continuously re-examines
them, right?
There's actually an API
as well that they offer.
So any third-party
application or browser
can leverage Safe Browsing.
And so when you think, what does
that have to do with phishing?
Well, on an Android device
where Chrome OS is your default
browser, you launch a link
from your text messaging
application, you launch
a link from your email,
you launch the
link from anywhere,
if it opens up with Chrome or
like a custom tab with Chrome,
you will see this pop up, OK?
So it does cover some of that.
And then when we talk about
additional phishing protection,
right?
So there's-- against phishing,
a lot of people talk about
step-up verification or
two-factor authentication.
So-- deep breath--
sorry, I get too excited.
There's still a flaw
with most versions
of two-factor
authentication out there.
So if you do like SMS-based
or phone-based or text or
OTP-based, you could still
provide that information
to whoever trying
to phish you, right?
So with hardware-backed keys,
though-- hardware-based keys,
rather--
it actually specifically
protects against that.
So like FIDO U2F, they actually
do a check to make sure
that you're hitting
the right URL,
and it's one of the
only ways to actually
truly protect against phishing.
And even internally, Google, I
think we talked about it last
year where since we've
implemented hardware-based keys
at Google, we have--
not a single employee has been
phished that we know of, right?
What's really
cool-- and I'm going
to spend a couple of slides on
this because it's the inverse,
we made a big
announcement yesterday.
And so the people that raised
their hand and said they
have an Android phone, we now
can leverage these Android
devices as actual
hardware security keys,
FIDO U2F keys to authenticate
with your laptop or desktop.
So now the phone
becomes the key, right?
And so this actually works
on Android Nougat and above.
So that's over a
billion Android devices
that can take advantage
of this functionality.
And it actually uses, again,
hardware-based security
because it's using that
trusted execution environment
to generate and
protect those keys that
are used in conjunction.
And then on the Pixel 3
specifically, it actually
uses that discrete hardware.
So just to give you an example
what that user experience looks
like.
You'll see when you try to log
onto your desktop or laptop,
to G Suite or to Gmail
or whatever, you'll
see a pop-up on your phone.
This is on a device that isn't--
this is not a Pixel
3 device example.
And you'll simply
just authenticate.
You hit Yes and
you're good to go.
On a Pixel 3 specifically
like I mentioned,
it leverages a discrete
tamper-resistant piece
of hardware called
the Titan M chip.
It's basically analogous
to a secure element--
it's a separate chip, hence
the really nice drawing there.
And the way that works is--
so the keys there are actually
stored in that
chip, and you have
to hard-press the Volume
Down button to prove intent
and that you're a person
present to authenticate.
So it provides a higher
level of assurance,
and again, these
chips are much more--
they protect much better
against hardware-based attacks.
Last one I wanted
to cover really
quickly was voice phishing
because I feel like this is
the one that's most annoying.
And again, not covering
every single example here.
There's obviously probably
sophisticated examples
that this wouldn't
cover, but this covers
some basic examples, right?
So according to First
Orion, almost half
of US cell phone calls will
be scams by the next year.
I'm sure everybody
here feels that pain.
I get a lot of these calls.
I didn't have to
mock up screenshots,
these are actual real
shots I took from my phone.
Well, the second one is not
because it's a fake number.
But like this
happens all the time.
So on Android Nougat
and above, again,
a billion-plus devices, if
you're using the default phone
application provided
by Google, this
is actually a built-in feature,
the caller ID spam protection.
So on other operating
systems that's something
you have to buy from a
third party or the carrier.
On Android, this is something
that you get for free, right?
This is a built-in feature.
You can actually say,
hey, if it's a spam call,
just don't even let it show up.
And the call screening is
a Pixel-exclusive feature
that launched with the Pixel
3, but it's actually become
my favorite feature by far.
Because if you really
want to annoy people
that try to phish
for information,
just turn on the call screening
and let them deal with that.
This is the coolest feature.
I use this 10 times a day.
The biggest mistake
I ever made, though,
was using it against my wife.
She still hasn't
forgiven me about that,
she brings it up all the time.
But it's actually
my coolest feature.
And just for the
fun of it, they've
added like saving
your transcript
so then you can read it later.
It's actually pretty amusing.
All right.
So now covering the end user,
the weakest link, the biggest
risk.
I had this really funny
definition of end user,
but they made me take it
down because it was mean,
but I'm going to say it anyways.
It was end user,
which is a noun,
and it's the term
IT professionals use
when they mean idiot.
So there, I've said it.
I took it off the slides but
I wanted to say it anyways.
It's pretty funny.
But again, I don't believe that.
I think end users
can be educated,
and they just don't
appreciate the risk they often
inflict on themselves and
the enterprise, right?
So just quick a couple
examples that I put together.
Obviously end users
sometimes don't
want to pay for
applications from the Play
Store or the iTunes
App Store, so they're
going to try to
side-load applications.
This is possible on iOS, this
is possible on Android, right?
End users tend to be really
finicky about not using
the IT-provided applications
for collaboration or content
creation or whatever.
So they're like, you know what?
I'll just use my
own applications
and make my life easier because
that's what I like to use
and I'm stubborn.
And of course, end users try
to root devices or jailbreak
their devices because they
want to provide their own look
and feel or customization
that they maybe
aren't happy with the
stock version, right?
And so an interesting survey
from a couple of years
ago says nearly three out
of four government agencies
experienced a security
issue last year,
and 100% cite employees as their
largest security threat, OK?
So, since most people know
about Android Enterprise,
I think that's here
to help, right?
Android Enterprise
is here to help.
So obviously Android has
had Enterprise functionality
for many years,
going back to Froyo.
Early as Froyo you
could do basic stuff
with device administrator
APIs, but since then it's
evolved to something new
with Android Enterprise,
and we have 80-plus
management settings
that Enterprise
mobility manager vendors
or unified endpoint manager
vendors can take advantage
of and lock down these devices.
And what's nice about
Android Enterprise
is that it provides
nice data separation
from personal and work and it
provides multiple management
modes.
So let's take a look
at what that means.
So-- well first I
guess before that,
if you look at the evolution
of Android Enterprise,
it really started
with Lollipop where--
that's when we came up
with the work profile,
and kind of created
this paradigm shift.
And I'm going to cover
that in the next slide.
But you can see, we've
been steadily improving it.
So like in Marshmallow, we
added additional key sharing
functionality so
keys can be shared
across Enterprise applications.
So you don't have to like
share the same key somehow
across 15 different
applications on a device,
it could be centrally stored
and only work applications
can get access to it.
We added a work-specific
security challenge in Nougat.
We added zero touch
enrollment, which
I'll cover in the next slide.
And then we added--
in Pie, we refreshed
the user experience
to make it much more
elegant for end users.
So first and foremost, for
users to set up these devices,
times have changed.
When you had a BlackBerry
back in the day,
you kind of expected
IT to set up the device
and they'd hand it
off to the user.
Nowadays, users are
distributed across everywhere.
You mail that device to
the user and you just
pray that they can
follow the instructions.
So with Android Enterprise we
have quite a few different ways
to set up these devices.
So you can do a QR code, NFC
bump, short code identifier,
or zero touch,
which is basically--
how many people-- sorry
for all the survey
questions-- how many people
are familiar with zero touch
enrollment?
Cool.
OK, so zero touch is basically
analogous to Apple's Device
Enrollment program.
That zero to 60 fully
automated, the user
has to do nothing
basically, right?
But even with the other
options, it's pretty quick.
You scan whatever, you
enter your details,
and you're fully set up.
There's not much the user
has to do to deal with this.
And then when it comes
to the management modes,
so like I mentioned
earlier, Android Enterprise
provides quite a
bit of flexibility.
There's the work
profile for BYOD.
And this is like a big
game changer, because if--
prior to here I was at
VMware working with AirWatch.
Prior to that I was at a
startup called Good Technology.
So I come from the EMM space.
And at Good
Technology, we actually
created what we
call the container.
And the container was basically
the solution where we said,
you know what?
We're going to provide
managed applications where
you don't manage
a device, but you
can manage your own BYOD
applications, right?
These line of business apps.
And that was really good at the
time because it solved the gap,
but if you look at the way
Android Enterprise handles
the work profile, it removes
the need for these containers,
because containers
were proprietary.
These were like-- every
vendor has their own SDK,
and they have their own
line of business apps.
So if you move from
one EMM to another
and you try to do
the same model,
you basically have to
switch all your apps around,
they don't all work the same.
With Android Enterprise
and the work profile,
the work profile is
that container, right?
It basically segregates
all your enterprise data.
You can distribute
apps to that--
that are commercially off
the shelf from the Play
Store or your enterprise apps.
They don't have to be wrapped
or customized in any way, right?
So it doesn't matter
which EMM vendor you use,
you kind of lift and shift, to
steal, I guess, a cloud term.
And you can switch
vendors easily
without any friction or impact
to your environment, right?
In terms of device management.
And then on the
company-owned side,
obviously there's a lot of
different options you have.
You can do a
fully-managed device
where you don't let them put any
personal data on that device,
or you can do a-- fully
manage with a work
profile where you
still give them
access to personal
data on the device,
but it's a fully-managed
device, and you still
segregate your work data.
So that's a really good example
for heavily regulated customers
that are really
security-conscious.
And then you could do dedicated
devices for rugged or retail
or warehouse scenarios, right?
So in terms of--
it benefits both, right?
So I think I
covered this before,
but in terms of
the work profile,
it's a separate Linux
user on the device.
So like, you're a personal
user, which is like user 0.
The Linux user-- the second
work profile user is user 10.
They're both available.
So you can see on
the screen there--
I wish I had a laser pointer.
You can see on the screen
there that on one side
you have personal, on the
other side you have work,
but it's not like a desktop
where you log out of one
and log into the other.
They're available
at the same time--
this is just the
application drawer,
but you can pin these on your
screen, so wherever they are--
the only difference is you see--
there are some with a lock,
and the others are not.
And you actually
can have the same--
you have two Chromes, you can
have two Gmail or whatever
clients you want.
One is for work,
one is for personal,
they're completely segregated
from one another, right?
And the real nice
benefit is you can
do whatever you want in that
work profile, fully manage it.
You can do VPN just
for those work apps.
You can do whatever restrictions
and controls you want.
Or, again, you can
manage the entire device
and lock down
everything you would
like you used to do
with a BlackBerry
or you do on an iPhone
where you can restrict
access to camera,
what keyboard you use,
don't let them modify Wi-Fi
and so forth-- there's
80-plus management policies.
But the real cool thing is it
benefits the end user, right?
So the nice thing
about the work profile
is it gives them peace of mind.
Again, coming from
the EMM space,
the thing that bothered
me the most is like, when
you install a device
management profile and it says,
you can trust us.
We won't scan, inventory all
your personal apps, it's OK.
Yes, we have the
permission, but we
promise we're not going
to do that for you.
With the work profile,
it's just not possible.
The user knows what they're
getting into, and IT knows what
they're getting into because
there's comfortable balance
there that IT is comfortable
that nothing will be able
to get to this work data, and
the user knows that IT cannot
overreach.
The only things that IT
can do in this scenario
when it's just work profile
is they can basically
force the device passcode, and
like for example, as reaching
outside of the work profile,
and now they can basically--
as of Q, which is going to
covered in the other session,
for example, you can ensure that
unknown sources is turned off
on the personal side
so they can't side-load
any applications at all.
That's the only overreach right
now on the work profile, right?
So like outside of
the work profile.
So it provides that
perfect balance.
And actually, that
little toggle, people
always think about turning
off their work profile.
Yeah, I'm on vacation, I'm
going to turn this thing off
and I don't think about
email or whatever.
I think of it actually as a
really cool security feature,
because I give my phone
to my kids all the time.
And the worst thing
that can ever happen
is my kid launches an email
client and responds to my boss
with gibberish.
And what am I going to--
I've been breached,
I've been breached.
So in terms of the next
piece, so we talked
about the separation of data,
but how do you get applications
in there?
So we offer something
called Managed Google Play,
and basically it's
the same thing.
It's the same infrastructure
that hosts millions of apps
already for the
Play Store, but this
is for enterprise customers.
And so imagine on a
fully-managed device,
IT curates what applications
are available to the users,
so you can define the
list of applications.
And this covers that
example of like users trying
to do their own thing with
their own set of applications
for work-related activity.
This will help solve
that problem, right?
You can push out applications
that you deem are appropriate,
whether they're available
through the Play Store already
or you just deploy
enterprise applications.
And you can also push them--
like without the
user intervention
and remove them from the device
without user intervention.
Set update policies for
them if you wanted to.
I heard a customer example
where they actually said,
we don't want auto updates.
We're really worried
because we have
to vet these apps in advance,
and certain app developers
are so agile, they
release updates every day
and we just can't keep up.
And so you can
control that, right?
So that's the benefit
of Managed Google Play.
And then with the work
profile, it's even better
because you can
let the user have
a personal instance of
Play on the personal side,
let them install whatever
they want from the Play Store,
and then you have
the work side, right?
So you control their work apps,
you ensure that, for example,
if they can only use
one document repository,
they can't install their
personal one into that side
and share data between the two,
so they can't take their work
data with them somewhere
else and work on it
with their own
preferred application.
So it provides that
really nice separation.
And then there's also a thing
called Manage App Configuration
where historically
what you would do
is like an enterprise app
or-- an app developer that's
in the App Store but targets
Enterprise would say,
you know what?
I need to build
like customizations
for every customer.
Well with Manage App
Config, they basically
provide the hooks, and
then through the EMM,
you can basically
define whether you
want to turn some
bells and whistles
off in their specific
application, right?
So it generalizes that, so it
could apply to any Enterprise
customer without having to
do all these various one-off
configurations.
So like I mentioned earlier, one
of the things we really look at
is, are our security
investments paying off, right?
And it's really important.
We call it measurable
security, right?
How do we measure success
in what we're doing?
And so Gartner publishes
a comprehensive mobile OS
comparison report every year.
This is actually the
previous year's report.
The new one is coming out
imminently-- actually,
we were hoping it came out
before this, but it didn't.
And so they have 28 categories,
and it's about 16 categories
of built-in security
features that just
should be built into a phone.
And these could include,
for example, OS updates,
app updates, network
security, network encryption,
authentication security,
exploit protection.
And then on the
Enterprise controls,
it's the stuff
you would expect--
key management, authentication
management, policy management,
and so forth.
Anyways, as you can see, if you
look at the orange rectangle,
you'll see that the
way they scored this
was basically weak,
average, strong, right?
Low, medium, high.
And what you'll see is that
the three devices or the three
columns that scored the highest
were all Android, right?
So it was Android Oreo, it
was the Pixel 2 running Oreo,
and it was a Samsung
device running Oreo, right?
They scored the
highest in this report.
Specifically the
Pixel scored strong
in 24 out of 28 categories.
And iOS, you can see
yourselves, scored 12 strong out
of 28 categories, right?
So this is how we
measure success, right?
We want to make sure that
analysts are taking a look
and evaluating what we provide.
So anyways, let's quickly recap.
I don't really need
this slide, but just
save some time for questions.
But basically, again, I
tried to do it a little
differently today just
covering system-related risk,
app-related risk, things that
we can help with phishing
that's just built in.
And the end user is the
biggest risk, right?
And so thank you very much.
One thing to point out--
if you're interested,
if you want to get
more information,
we recently refreshed
our security site,
it's called the Android
Security Center.
It's android.com/security.
And since this is the
last one of the day,
please be generous and
be nice on the surveys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]